Hello world.
It's the Raj and do you own your data?
No.
I'm going to demo an open source project
that aims to bring power back to the
people called open mind.
It's a community focused on building
technology for decentralized ownership of
data and AI.
The original dream for the web was
for everyone to be able to participate
equally for the betterment of humanity.
The webs first pioneers had the ethos
that data should be freely available for
all that wanted.
At its start,
the web was just a series of nodes
joined by links with no central node.
Everyone hosted their own
data on their own server,
but this altruism begin to fade
during the first.com bubble.
Entrepreneurs realize that an easy way
to provide value on top of this neutral
playing field was to build centralized
services that collected data and
monetized it.
You freely exchanged your
data to access a free service,
but what's happened now is that these
services now own the majority of the
world's data.
The web has become centralized.
Let's say we want to start an AI startup,
meaning we want to use
AI to solve some problem.
The current business model for this
is to first acquire data about people
somehow.
The next step is to train a model on that
data so that it does something useful
and the last step is to sell the use of
that model in the form of a usable APP.
The problem with this business model is
that people lose control of their data
and aren't compensated for it.
Open mind is a peer to peer network that
lets anyone train their AI models on
user data that normally only big companies
had access to while letting users
maintain ownership and get compensated
for their data and achieves this by
sprinkling for newer technologies
on itself. Deep learning,
federated learning,
homomorphic encryption and
blockchain smart contracts.
Let's go over each at a high
level. First, deep learning.
This is a way to convert one dataset
into another dataset so we can go from a
partially labeled Dataset of Mri Scans
to a fully labeled Dataset of Mri Scans.
The next technology is federated learning.
Normally you'd collect some data set from
users and store it all on one server.
You then train your model on that server.
So the data and the model
are in the same place.
Federated Learning flips the script.
Instead of bringing all the
data to the models location,
we bring the model to each
individual data source. Lastly,
the model is then updated in the cloud
using all the gradients it receives.
The third technology is
called homomorphic encryption.
This is a scheme that lets you perform
computation on values that you don't know
the actual value of just the cipher text.
So if you have a number like five you
can homomorphic Lee encrypted into a
cipher text than perform operations on
that cipher using known values and get
results all without ever knowing
the real value of the cipher.
The last one is called blockchain
smart contract technology.
A blockchain is a decentralized database.
It's immutable so no one can delete
an old entry and no one can fake a new
entry. A copy of it is stored on
every node that makes up its network.
A smart contract is some data
that's stored on the blockchain.
This data usually includes an event,
some state and some code.
It's like a regular
app but de centralized.
So what is open minds workflow look like?
Assuming we only use deep learning
and federated learning together,
we as a startup can say,
let's train our model using
three different people's data.
So we first train it on user A's data,
the model updates,
Aka gradients are sent back to us.
Then we do the same for
the other users at first.
This seems good enough since everyone
got to maintain control of their data and
our startup didn't have to see any of
the user's data to train our models on
that data.
The problem though is that any of these
users could just steal the model when
they receive a copy of it
and sell it themselves. Also,
the gradients give hints about the
type of data a user has and lastly,
no one got paid for their data.
What if we sprinkle some home
morphic encryption on this?
Meaning we encrypt our model before
we send it out to users for training.
Well,
user a would increase the intelligence
of the model by training it on their own
data and can't see what
the model's values are.
Same for the other two users so
they couldn't steal the model,
but our startup could still
reverse engineer user's
data and users still aren't
being paid for their data.
Enter blockchain smart
contracts are startup consent
as model specification to a
smart contract.
That means the type of model we want
to use and some money in the form of a
bounty that we want to pay for the model.
The smart contract initializes the model
itself because the weights are randomly
initialized by the smart contract and all
the information used to initialize the
weights is public.
There are no hidden secrets inside the
homomorphic encryption that our startup
could embed to make it so that the model
secretly memorizes user data when user
a request the model specs from the
smart contracts, they can agree,
let the model Spec train on their
data and send it back the gradients.
The smart contract evaluates
the validity of those gradients,
then sends them to some bounty
in the form of cryptocurrency.
Now we can't steal their data
and they can't steal our model.
Plus it creates a marketplace so
users get paid for their data.
The only remaining problem now is that
whoever holds the public private keys for
the homomorphic encryption can decrypt
any part of the system at any time.
The solution is to use an oracle,
so the difference would be that the smart
contract sends the model Spec to the
Oracle. It generates a public
private key pair and crips.
The model then sends it
back to the smart contract,
so the Oracle holds the key pairs
after training on all the user data.
The model is sent back to the Oracle.
It's decrypted encrypted with
the oracles keys then sent back.
Since the oracle acts as
a trusted third party,
no one can decrypt the model or gradients.
A second smart contract can act as an
insurance policy against the oracle
sharing its secret keys.
If we look at the open mind,
get hub account will notice
quite a lot of moving parts.
This is a big project with many
contributors and growing daily.
There are four main components though.
The first is sonar,
which is the federated learning server.
It's a smart contract running on the
Theorem blockchain that handles all
activity.
This contract holds bounties and pointers
to AI models in the form of Ip fs
addresses.
That's where the models are stored.
Sonar has an interface to it as well that
we interact with to train our models.
It communicates with capsule,
which is a third party Django web app
used to generate PGP public and private
keys for encrypting models that anyone
can host as an oracle users store their
data in a mine.
This is a node dot.
JS client that acts as a safe warehouse
for data and communicates with sonar
constantly checking for new models to
contribute relevant data to users can pull
their data from existing centralized
services via custom adapters.
The idea is that you can download your
Facebook or Google data directly into
your mind.
Then sell it for models to train on.
The last component is sift,
which is a neural network library that
can be trained in a homomorphic Lee
encrypted state.
Let's say we're trying to predict whether
or not someone has diabetes or not.
A data scientist will first create a
request to sonar in order to begin a
training campaign.
They define a set of basic parameters
like the amount of money they're willing
to spend in order to train their model.
A description of the data being requested
from the minds like certain images,
a description of the desired
output like image labels,
the starting accuracy
and the desired accuracy.
A model is generated from this campaign
and place on the sonar blockchain sonar
communicates with capsule which
generates a public private key.
A public key is sent back to
sonar and stored with the model.
The private key is kept secret in the
capsule minds can pull the model and train
it.
After training.
The gradients are uploaded back to
the sonar blockchain and the change in
accuracy is calculated
when training is complete.
The encrypted model has sent to the
capsule to be decrypted using the private
key then delivered to the data scientist.
Three things to remember here.
The web has become way too centralized
of a few people are profiting off the
data of many.
A great potential solution is open mind.
A project that aims to create a
marketplace to let data scientists trained
models and pay users for their data
directly and open mind uses four key
technologies, deep learning, federated
learning, homomorphic encryption,
and blockchain smart contracts.
This week's coding challenge is to
make a contribution to open minds.
They've got lots of
issues on their get hubs,
so just pick one and make a pull
request with your contribution.
The more valuable, the better posts your
get hub link in the comment section,
and I'll announce the winners next week.
Hey,
I hope you liked this
video and if you did,
please hit that subscribe button for now.
I've got to go own my data,
so thanks for watching.